want to to go in on as you know the
government have denied it boris johnson
has denied it on the record other
sources have said
the big question is whether any evidence
emerges
that he did actually say it or any of
these sources
actually go here at the record uh i'm
not going to speculate on what he did or
didn't say adam
i mean what are people saying he has
said on the record that he didn't
say it mps say to me privately it's the
sort of thing
that they could imagine him saying but
the prime minister has
denied it and and the key question is
are any of the sources actually going to
go
on the record and say that this is what
he said and challenge his
account i mean other people have
suggested that maybe he said something
to the effect but it's been interpreted
in different ways okay we will find out
uh bethlehem thank you very much indeed
prime minister's questions coming up at
noon stay with sky news
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
just coming to an end we're going to go
to prime minister's questions likely to
be dominated by allegations of sleaze
downing street has just confirmed the
appointment of lord guyt
as a new investigator of ministers
standards and interests and it does say
uh that the prime minister and lord guys
have agreed the first thing he'll do is
look into the refurbishment of the
downing street flat let's go over to the
prime minister we're supporting
india with vital medical equipment and
we will continue to work closely
with the indian authorities to determine
what further help they may need
mr speak mr speaker i also welcome last
week's court of appeal decision
to overturn the convictions of 39 former
subpostmasters in the horizon dispute
an appalling injustice so when williams
is leading an ongoing independent
inquiry
that will report this summer mr speaker
this morning i had meetings with
ministerial colleagues
another and others in addition to my
duties in this house i shall have
further such meetings
later today let's go to andrew jenkins
andrea
you're on your tapping country
have you got the answer
tell us more about pmq's i'm sure the
prime minister knows the answer
prime minister
you can't do it what what i'm going to
do i'm going to try and come back i'm
gonna go to
leader of the opposition kirsten
uh thank you mr speaker can i join the
prime minister and his remarks about the
humanitarian disaster
we're witnessing in india i know the uk
has already committed
some support but given the scale and
gravity of the disaster
i hope the foreign secretary will set
out today what more the uk will do to
help the indian people
in their hour of need can i also join
the prime minister in his remarks about
the post office
case an ongoing injustice and of course
today is international workers memorial
day
and this day uh this year after all the
sacrifices
our frontline workers have made during
the pandemic it's even more poignant
than usual i join in solidarity with all
those morning loved ones
today mr speaker it was reported this
week
including in the daily mail the bbc and
itv
backed up by numerous sources
that the end of october the prime
minister said he would rather
have and i quote bodies pile
high than implement another lockdown
can the prime minister tell the house
categorically
yes or no did he make those remarks
or remarks to that effect prime minister
no mr speaker and i think what i think
the right honorable gentleman is a is a
lawyer i'm given to understand i think
uh that if he's going to repeat
allegations like that
he should come to this house and
substantiate those allegations
and say and say where he heard them and
who who exactly
who exactly is supposed to have said
those who exactly is supposed to have
said
those things mr speaker uh because uh
what i certainly can tell him uh and he
asked about the october
decisions they were very bitter very
difficult decisions as they would be for
any
prime minister mr speaker because no one
wants to put this country
uh into a lockdown with all the
consequences that means
the loss of education for the damage uh
to people's life chances
to the huge medical backlog that it
entails but it was thanks to that
lockdown
the tough decision that we took mr
speaker
that and thanks to the heroic efforts of
the british people that we have got
through
to the this stage in the pandemic where
we find ourselves rolling out
our vaccine where we've done 50 percent
of the population 25 percent
of the adult population have now had two
doses
mr speaker and i want to i knocked downs
lockdowns are miserable lockdowns are
appalling things to have to do
but i i have to say that i believe that
we had absolutely no choice
well somebody here isn't telling the
truth the house will have heard the
prime minister's answer and i remind him
the minister of code says and i quote
ministers who knowingly mislead
parliament will be expected to offer
their resignation
i'll leave it there for now turning to
another issue
who who will be further on this
will be further on this believe you me
who initially and prime minister
initially
is the key word here who initially
paid for the redecoration of his downing
street flat
prime minister mr speaker when it comes
to misleading parliament he may
recollect that it was only a few weeks
ago
uh that he said uh that he submitted
that he didn't oppose this government
uh those countries stay in the uh
leaving the european medicines agency
the fact that he was then
uh forced to retract and leaving the
european medicines agency was absolutely
invaluable
uh for our vaccine rhode island actually
it was just last week
uh that he that he said that james dyson
he said that james dyson was a
personal friend of mine a fact that
james dyson was corrected
uh in the newspaper this morning uh as
for as for
the the the latest stuff that he's uh
that he's bringing up he should know
that i paid for
uh dining street refurbishment
personally uh mr speaker
and i can try contrast it uh i can trust
it
and any any any further declaration that
i have to
uh make i will if if any of what i will
be advised upon
by lord guys but if he talks about
housing costs uh mr speaker then the
people of this country can make their
own decision
in just eight days time because on
average labor councils charge you 93
pounds more
in vandy the conservative councils and
liberal democrat councils charge you 120
pounds more that i think is the issue
that i think is the issue upon which the
british people would like him
to focus yes mr speaker normally when
people don't want to incriminate
themselves they go no comment
let me ask this let me gave well
let's let's explore this bit further
prime minister
let's ask it a different way either this
is the initial
invoice prime minister initial invoice
either the taxpayer paid the initial
invoice
or it was the conservative party or it
was a private donor
or it was the prime minister so i'm
making it easy for the prime minister
it's now
multiple choice there are only four
options it should be easier than finding
the chatty rats
mr speaker so i asked the prime minister
again who
paid the initial invoice initially in
voice prime minister
for the redecoration of the prime
minister's flat the initial invoice
i'm mr speaker i've given him the answer
and the answer is i have i have covered
the costs and i think most people will
find it absolutely
bizarre and of course there's an
electoral commission uh invested
investigating this and i
i can tell him that i've conformed in
full with the code of conduct with
uh and uh ministers ministerial uh code
and
i've uh officials who have been kept uh
uh
have been advising me throughout this
whole thing but i think people will
think it absolutely
bizarre that he is focusing on
this issue uh where what people want to
know is uh what plans a labour
government might have
to improve uh the life of people in this
country and let me tell you if he talks
about housing again
we're helping people on the house i'd
rather not spend taxpayers money by the
way
like the last labour government would
spend 500 000 pounds
of taxpayers money on the dining street
fact i'd rather
if i i would that yes they did yes they
did
tarting it up i i would much rather i
would much rather help
people on the get on the property ladder
and it's this
conservative government that has built
244
000 homes in the last year which is a
record over 30 years this is a
government that gets on with delivering
on the people's priorities while he
continues to raise his
i think issues that most people would
find irrelevant to their concerns
mr speaker he talks about priorities
what's he spending his time doing
this is a prime minister who during the
pandemic was nipping out of meetings to
choose wallpaper
at 840 pounds or all a roll
last week just last week he spent his
time phoning journalists
to moan about his old friend dominic
cummings
and he's telling the civil service to
find out who paid for the redecoration
the cabinet secretary has been asked to
investigate
who paid for the refurbishments in the
flat why doesn't the primes just
tell him that would be the end of the
investigation
mr speaker it's been widely reported
that lord brownlow
who just happens to have been given a
perish by the conservative party
was asked to donate 58 000 pounds to
help repay for the cost of this
refurbishment
can the prime minister if he's so keen
to answer confirm did
lord brownlow make that payment for that
purpose
prime minister mr speaker i think i've
answered this question uh
several times now and and the answer the
answer is that i have covered the cost
i have met the uh requirements that i've
been obliged to meet
in full and uh when it comes to when it
comes to
the taxpayer and the costs of number 10
dining street it was the labor
it was the previous labor camp i think
tony blair racked up a bill
of 350 000 pounds and i think what the
people of this country
want to see is that is minimizing uh
taxpayer expense they want to see a
government that's focused
on their needs and delivering more homes
for the people of this country
and cutting council tax which is what
we're doing and it's on that basis that
i think people are going to judge
our parties on may the dear star
answer the question that's what the
public's scream at their televisions
every pm fuse answer the question the
prime minister hasn't answered the
question
he knows he hasn't answered the question
he never answers the question
the prime minister the prime minister
will be aware that he's required to
declare
any benefits that relates his political
activities including loans or credit
arrangements within 28 days 28 days
prime minister yes
he will also know that only donation
must be recorded in the register of
ministers interests
and under the law any donation of over
500 pounds at a political party
must be registered and declared so the
rules are very clear
the electoral commission now think
that there are reasonable grounds to
suspect that an offence or offenses
may have occurred that's incredibly
serious
can the prime minister tell the house
does he believe
that any rules or laws have been broken
in relation to the refurbishment of the
prime minister's flat
prime minister no i don't mr speaker
what i what
what i believe has been strained to
breaking point is the credulity of the
public
uh he has half an hour every week to put
serious and sensible questions
to me about the state of the pandemic
about the vaccine rolex about what we're
doing to support our nhs about what
we're doing to fight crime about what
we're doing to bounce back
from this uh pandemic about the economic
recovery about jobs
for the people of this country and he
goes on and on mr speaker about
wallpaper when
as i've told him umpteen times now i pay
for it
mr speaker can i remind the prime
minister of the nolan principles which
are meant to govern
the behavior of those in public office
they're these
selflessness integrity
objectivity accountability
openness honesty
and leadership instead what do we get
from this prime minister and this
conservative government
dodgy contracts jobs for their mates and
cash for access
and who's at the heart of it the prime
minister major sleaze
sitting there mr speaker
meanwhile he talks about priorities
crime is going up
nhs waiting lists are at record levels
and millions of people are worried about
their jobs
including liberty speed steel mr speaker
don't the british people deserve a prime
minister they can trust
and a government that isn't mired in
sleaze cronyism
and scandal mr speaker mr speaker last
week he came to this chamber
and he attacked me for talking to james
dyson about
ventilators where we're now sending
ventilators to help the people of india
and the following day
the following day mr speaker the labour
front bench said that
any prime minister in my position would
have done exactly the same thing
it wasn't only a few months ago that
they were actually attacking kate
bingham
saying she was a crony when she helped
to set up the vaccine task force
that delivered millions of vaccines for
the people of this country mr speaker is
helping us to get out of the pandemic
this is a government that is getting on
with delivering on the people's
priorities
we're rolling out many more nurses ten
thousand more nurses in the nhs
now than there were this time last year
8771 more police officers
on our streets now than they were when i
was elected including tougher sentences
mr speaker for serious sexual and
violent criminals which he opposed
mr speaker we're getting on and by the
way i forgot to mention it i forgot to
mention it
last night our friends in in the
european union voted to approve our
brexit deal
which he which he opposed which enables
us not just to take back control of our
borders mr speaker but to deliver free
of
which it does which he fervently opposed
and they enabling us
enabling us amongst other things to deal
with such threats
as the european super league uh mr
speaker but it enables us to deliver
free
ports in places like t-side and above
all
taking back control of our country has
allowed us to deliver the fastest
vaccine roll-out
in europe as he well knows which speaker
which would not have been possible
it would not have been possible if we'd
stayed in the european
medicine agency which he voted for mr
speaker
week after week the people of this
country can see the difference between
the labour party
the twists and turns with the wind that
thinks of nothing
except playing political games whereas
this
party gets on with delivering on the
people's priorities
and i hope that people will vote
conservative on may the 6th
let's see if we can comment down a
little joy morrissey
thank you mr speaker the uk is indeed a
world leader in covet 19 vaccination
may i thank the prime minister for the
swift action he has taken to deliver
this for our country
and will the prime minister join me in
thanking the many local volunteers such
as kirsty griffith
who has been volunteering at the marlow
vaccine center and guy hollis
and paul bass who who have been
volunteering alongside the denim
um community health and thank you for
the vaccine roll out in south box
uh well she my my honorable friends
should thank everybody involved and it's
been a fantastic national
effort led uh by the the nhs led by
overwhelmingly by gps but also by many
others by local council
uh officers uh officials uh by the army
by many others and of course
huge numbers of volunteers in in her
constituency and elsewhere i thank
kirsty griffith sky hollis and paul bass
very much for everything they've done
let's go to the leader of the snp
ian blackford ian thank you mr speaker
and can i
associate myself with the remarks of the
prime minister and leader of the
opposition over the humanitarian
crisis in india and the injustice over
the horizon issue at the post office
mr speaker over 127
000 people have died from covert in the
united kingdom
people have lost their mothers and
fathers their grandparents and even
their children
nhs staff have given their all fighting
to keep people alive
that's why so many people find the prime
minister's remark
that he would rather let their bodies
pile high in their thousands
than go into lockdown utterly utterly
sickening
the bbc and itv have multiple sources
confirming
that this is what the prime minister
said people are willing to go under oath
mr speaker
confirming that the prime minister said
these exact words
under oath mr speaker now parliamentary
rules stop me from saying
that the prime minister has repeatedly
lied to the public over the last week
but can i ask the question are you a
liar prime minister
prime minister uh mr speaker
i i leave it to you to judge whether the
uh arrival gentleman's
uh remarks were in order but i what i
will say to him
is that unfortunately
well we're not savory and not what we
would expect
i'm grateful to you mr speaker uh but
what i would say to the
uh right honourable uh gentleman is that
if he is going to
relay that kind of uh that kind of
quotation it is up to him in a place
like parliament
to produce the author uh who the person
who claims to have heard
it because i can't find them uh he says
that they're willing to
to go on earth perhaps they're they're
sitting somewhere in this in this
building i rather doubt it uh because
uh because i didn't say those words what
i do believe is that a lockdown is a
miserable miserable thing and i did
everything i could to try to protect the
british public throughout the pandemic
to protect them from lockdowns but also
to protect them uh from disease and he's
right to draw attention to them
to the to the wretched uh toll uh that
that kovid has
has brought and we grieve and i know the
whole house breathes for every
family that has lost a loved one it has
been a it has been a horrendous time
but it is thanks to that lockdown and
the vaccine
rollout combined with the vaccine
rollout though we are making the
progress
we are and i i i may say oh we're making
progress
across the whole of the united kingdom
let's go back to in blackfoot
thank you mr speaker and of course it's
the prime minister's behavior which is
not in order this is a prime minister
who is
up to his neck and a swamp of tony
sleeves
we've seen contracts for bronies tax for
tax breaks
and cash for curtains the prime minister
has
dodged these questions all week and he's
dodged them again today
but these questions simply are not going
to go away so when exactly was money
funneled through
tory hq into his personal bank account
when did he pay back this money
was it an interest-free loan and who is
the donor our donors
who originally funded it is the prime
minister aware
that if he continues to fail to answer
these questions that the electoral
commission
has the powers to prosecute him will the
prime minister
publish these details today but is he
going to wait until the police come
knocking
at his door yeah
mr speaker as i've said i look forward
to what the electoral commission has to
uh has to say uh but i can tell him that
for the rest of it he's talking complete
nonsense and
uh it is the only thing i will say is
that
uh it is thanks to our investment uh in
uh in policing uh that we're going to
have another 20 000 more officers on
this on the street
of our of the streets of our country
that is a fantastic thing and
we will be making sure that that gets
through uh to scotland as well what we
want to see
what we want to see is a scottish
nationalist government
stop obsessing about breaking up our
country which is all they
all they can think about and talk about
and talk about
tackling crime and using that investment
to fight crime which is i think what the
people of scotland want to see
gary somer thank you mr speaker if the
prime minister was to walk down
bristol road staff in longbridge today
he would see a small army of jcb
diggers leveling out the old mg rover
westwork site
to provide one of the biggest leveling
up projects locally with 5000 extra jobs
at an industrial site
but what people want to see too is the
regeneration of northfield high street
with a proper plan
and money on the table and so does the
prime minister agree with me
that we need people like andy street
driven and energetic mayors
delivering for the west midlands working
with me and local conservative
councillors to deliver on this plan
because after all mr speaker teamwork
makes the dream work
yeah mr speaker i i i've lost an
admiration for what andy street is doing
he's a fantastic mayor
of the west midlands and he's got a
fantastic vision
for transport for jobs for growth and
recovery and i hope everybody votes for
andy street on may the 6th
right let us go to liz savile roberts
liz
i think it's worth repeating the
ministerial code seven guiding
principles
selflessness integrity objectivity
accountability
openness honesty and leadership
the prime minister has spent the week
ticking them off on his don't do list
at the same time he tries to play down
allegations of saying
let the bodies pile high given that the
sole
judge on questions relating to the
conduct of ministers
and the conduct of the prime minister is
the prime minister himself
what happens when a prime minister goes
rogue
uh mr speaker the people of this country
have a chance to
uh make their own minds up on on may the
sixth and
uh they when they look at uh what's
happening in wales
uh mr speaker they have a chance to um
make a choice
between a uh uh well i'm afraid a
continually failing welsh
labor government uh or welsh
conservative
uh administration uh in cardiff i i
believe has a fantastic vision 65 000 uh
high skill high paid jobs
doing up there finally addressing the
problems of the a55
getting 5 000 uh more teachers 3 000
more nurses
into into the welsh nhs uh solving the
problems of the m4 which i've spoken
about so movingly
many times uh in this chamber uh before
mr speaker
i hope uh that people will avoid voting
uh for
for for plague conrad and that they will
vote uh for
welsh conservatives on may the sixth in
wales
duncan baker mr speaker as
probably the only former subpost master
in parliament
last sunday last friday's ruling was the
beginning
not the end yes it will cost a lot of
money and yes it would take
time and there was more compensation
that is needed but does the prime
minister agree with me that only
a proper judge-led public inquiry can
really bring
justice to those victims of this a
permanent
accounting scandal and also hold to
account
those involved behind the scenes
uh i i i share i'm so i'm grateful to my
honorable friend for uh his expertise in
this matter and
uh thank him for uh for what he has just
said because he's
totally right i think that uh what
happened to those post office
uh workers the postmasters and some
postmasters was appalling it was one of
the biggest miscarriages of justice
in our history uh mr speaker and we are
looking indeed at uh the issues
uh involved and uh the former high court
judge sirwin williams uh will be making
uh recommendations about what further
actions what further apologies uh we
need to make
let's go to howard williams how
thank you mr speaker the pm uh just
raised the master of the world's general
election
well in march last year this united
kingdom conservative government
intercepted the deal between wales and
the roche pharmaceutical company
for 5 000 daily covet tests
instructing the company to reserve all
additional covet tests
to england those tests would have been
crucial to saving thousands of lives in
wales
so as we go to the polls next week will
the prime minister tell us
why welsh lives meant so little to him
uh mr speaker i'm afraid he the the
honourable german is completely
wrong in what he says about tess but i
can tell him uh i can tell him that he's
right about one thing which is that
wells has made an amazing contribution
to our national our uk fight back
against
kovid and it was incredible to again to
go uh to the wackart factory
in wrexham uh to go to that site and
it's it's work working together with
oxford biomedica that has enabled us
to roll out the oxford astrazeneca
vaccine uh mr speaker that has made such
a difference
and i i want to say a massive thank you
again
to those those welsh scientists all
those people working in that
factory because they have helped to save
countless lives across the uk
thank you mr speaker the integrated
review confirms the vital role the
atomic weapons establishment in
berkshire will play in our future
nuclear capability
i want to pay tribute to them and
particularly to the senior female
employees who have won
a slew of national awards for their work
in defence science engineering and
nuclear security
given the government's significant
investment in all these sectors would my
right honourable friend
say how he plans to improve women's
participation in these fields
where they've been historically
underrepresented and could i invite him
to the awe to illustrate our success yes
i i will be honored to take up her
invitation here as soon as i
i can uh in terms of the female
representation in that sector she should
of course knows
that alison atkinson became the chief
executive officer and manager of awe
uh in in may 2020 and there are huge
numbers of opportunities
uh for women to join our our armed
services thanks mr speaker above all to
the biggest uplift in defence spending
since the end of the cold war
let's go to sir mate thank you very much
mr speaker
i welcome uh the prime minister's
commitment last week
to include aviation and shipping into
our target emission emissions but surely
the prime minister knows
that we will miss this target if we
proceed with a third runway at heathrow
and furthermore that that would
undermine the progress
that this government hopes to make
towards net zero so will the prime
minister take this opportunity
to commit to amending the airport's
national policy statement
in light of these commitments
mr speaker i the the third runway at
heathrow is as she knows a a private
sector
uh venture it's up to them to produce
the the capital to to do it i don't see
any immediate sign of that particular
project
coming off i think what we should be
looking at instead and what we are
looking at
is the prospect of jet zero aviation mr
mr speaker
of flying uh without carbon uh emissions
uh with far lower carbon emissions and
uh it is in that area that
uh the department of the bays uh and the
dft
are working together with the
manufacturers so that this ca this
country
leads in guilt-free flying
thank you mr speaker right now in every
part of the country levels of business
optimism
are higher than they have been since the
start of the pandemic
with many firms planning to hire more
staff and create more pr apprenticeships
for our young people
and there's one factor more than
anything else that underpins
that optimism and that is the success of
the uk
vaccination program so does my right
friend agree with
me that there's never been a more
important moment
for voters in scotland and in wales to
reject the negativity
and the divisiveness of the nationalists
and instead look forward to a brighter
and stronger future as one united
kingdom
[Music]
absolutely i don't know why the uh the
the shadow
uh leaders uh pbs is shaking her head
because
uh surely she would agree with that uh
we want to work together across the
whole of the uk and i
i pay tribute to as i have just said to
the incredible work of the
of the whatcart factory in wales but
there's also the valniva uh factory
uh in scotland uh and the whole of the
united kingdom coming together uh
represented by our armed services
and above all by our nhs helping to
deliver that vaccine
roll out to protect the country and take
it forward
let's go to janet david janet
thank you mr speaker it is absolutely
shocking
that we have heard the electoral
commission is investigating funding of
the prime minister's downing street flat
saying there are reasonable grounds to
suspect an offence
why does the prime minister think all of
these stories about sleaze
corruption and dishonesty keep happening
to him
and his conservative government
i tell you what mr speaker i think it's
because people are absolutely determined
uh to find anything they can hang on to
to talk about
except the vaccine rollout accept our
plans to unite and level up
across the country accept our plans to
fight crime
and give people the opportunity to buy
their own homes because they don't want
to discuss those issues because they
can't win
on those issues mr speaker because
they've got absolutely nothing to say
and that's what's become clear over the
last year
let's go to nick fletcher nick
thank you mr speaker before i ask my
question may i first ask the prime
minister to join me in thanking all the
staff at doncaster royal infirmary
and the emergency services for dealing
swiftly with a major water leak
yesterday
fortunately no one was hurt and all
patients have been moved safely to other
wards
however back to my original question the
local elections are only days away
and would therefore like to ask the
prime minister if he would offer his
full support
to doncaster conservative mayoral
candidate james hart
james like me is a local businessman and
will shout out for our town
and work closely with me on delivering
the government's leveling up agenda
minister well look i'm my my honorable
friend is absolutely right first of all
he's
he oh hang on he is right mr speaker
uh to want to thank all the staff of
doncaster royal infirmary
uh for what they did for the emergency
services in dealing with the incident
last night and i i'm glad to take that
opportunity but i'm also glad to take
the opportunity uh to support him
uh in his campaign for james hart and i
do hope that the people
of doncaster will go out to vote vote uh
and support him on may the sixth
revelation let's come to christian
matheson speaker the prime minister
promised in a series of texts to fix a
tax issue for his mate
sir james dyson at that dispatch box
last week he promised
to publish those texts because he's not
made good on that promise
so when will he publish them mr speaker
i promise to publish the
account of my dealings with james guys
which is exactly what i have done
and i can't believe they don't learn
their lesson mr speaker uh
they they're taxed they attacked the
government uh for having any kind of
discussions uh with a british ventilator
maker uh last week or potential
ventilator maker last week
and and then and then the following day
they did a a u-turn
and said that any prime minister would
do it and they've now done another a w
turn mr speaker and they're trying to
bash me again
which is it do you do you believe the
government should be supporting british
manufacturing delivering
vet ventilators yes or no that's the
question for labor
let's go to dr luke evans luke
mr speaker my constituency is best for
battle of bosworth but we also have many
other attractions like twice
zoom mallory racecourse burbage common
and thoughts and reservoir now these
attractions
all support superb cafes and pubs with
the bank holiday weekend coming up does
the prime minister have any plans
does he want to pop up to bosworth but
more importantly
what is the government doing to support
these attractions and domestic tourism
as we go into the summer
i want to thank my uh honorable friend i
want to tell him that no matter how many
pints
uh i joined him in lifting in the pubs
of bob's boss
but i could not do as much uh for the
economy
of bosworth as what we're already uh
doing with a 56 million pound welcome
back fund
uh probably even more welcome than my
presence in uh in bosworth
i bet you i venture to suggest uh the
hotly contested perhaps uh and
uh and that we've extended the cut in
vat for tourism and hospitality
uh to five percent right the way through
uh until the end
of september let's go to lillian
greenwood
lillian thank you mr speaker thank you
mr speaker
isn't the truth behind all of this the
sleaze
the scandals the jobs for your mates the
cash for curtains
that the prime minister thinks that
rules
laws and decency are for other people
the sort of people who shop at john
lewis or ikea or argos
who don't have wealthy donors to fund
their lifestyle
not for people like him and his
ministers
prime minister and mr speaker i think
what people think is the labour party
are losing all the arguments
across british politics they've got
nothing to say uh they've got no plan
for our future no vision for our country
they see a conservative government that
is getting on with uniting
and leveling up with the most ambitious
agenda any government has had for
generations
and i think that's what they're
listening to let's go
to ben bradley ben
i'm going to say next week residents
here in nottinghamshire will go out to
vote
the first time since that incredibly
successful 2019 election
where they elected a false late live to
them across every constituency
in this county despite that success many
areas like mansfield and much of the new
blue wall across the midlands and north
will still have mainly labour
councillors at a local level there's no
right to a friend have a message for
nothing voters who have the opportunity
next week to elect a conservative local
team
that can work with our mps to deliver
for nottinghamshire
i i want to ask i do and i want to thank
him for all the wonderful work that he
does
for his constituency my message would be
yes i hope that uh people
of nottinghamshire will uh get out and
vote conservative because if we who
share your priorities
on crime on the nhs on investment in
infrastructure and on leveling up across
our country so i hope you will vote
conservative on may the sixth
right let us go to rachel hopkins rachel
thank you mr speaker when was the prime
minister
and his chief of staff first made aware
of the plan for a european super league
i i first was made aware of the plan for
a european
super league on i think the sunday night
and
uh we acted decisively using
using the the arsenal of legislative
freedoms that we now have
thanks to leaving the european union
which he opposed uh of course was
reacted decisively
uh to make clear that the uk that the uk
government
the uk government took a dim view took a
dim view
of this matter mr speaker and the same
goes for my chief of staff
thank you mr speaker my constituency of
stroud recently won the best place to
live
and there is much to visit there
including
a historic lamp standard that was
erected
to celebrate queen victoria's diamond
jubilee
and next year our own queen will mark
her succession to the throne of 70 years
and i would ask the prime minister will
he join me in supporting
the gift being proposed by parliament to
mark her majesty's
platinum jubilee i i i want to thank
my honourable friend for a wonderful uh
proposal and i would certainly encourage
all colleagues
uh to support and to contribute to her
project
we're now going to go back to andrea
jenkins country
thank you mr speaker next week we will
look at healthiest
now does the prime minister agree with
me that for far too long labor have
taken our northern heartlands for
granted
on thursday the 6th of may will have the
opportunity to elect patriotic
hard-working northern look like matt
robinson ben helton and jill morton were
in hartlepool
they will be strong voices and champions
for infrastructure
and housing and jobs we must seize this
chance to build back better after the
pandemic and that only the conservatives
will deliver on
this uh
well mr speaker they don't like that
sort of thing do they they
they don't they don't like focusing they
don't like focusing on the issues that
actually matter to the
to the british people and the people of
of west yorkshire
i thank my honourable friend she's
absolutely right i hope they will go the
people on may the 6th will go
get out and vote for a party that
believes in supporting rnhs that
believes in fighting crime
not being soft on crime and that will
bring jobs
and regeneration across the entire
country and i hope that they will vote
conservative
on may the sixth order i'm not
suspending the house for three minutes
to enable the necessary arrangements for
the next business
so a fairly tense uh session of prime
minister's questions the last one for a
while because of
the elections uh next week uh probably
be remembered
because the prime minister repeatedly
didn't answer the question
as to who paid for the initial uh
redecoration of his flat that's now
under investigation by
a number of bodies including the
electoral commission and the new
uh commissioner looking into uh
ministers interests
lord gait who's been appointed however
he did make a categorical denial
no he did not make the remark about
being prepared to see bodies piled high
uh in the third wave of covid
uh kierstarma stuck to the questions uh
and by the end boris johnson was pretty
angry
at being pressed repeatedly did say that
people weren't interested in it
but also worth noting that uh kiestarma
who's been mocked by the prime minister
as captain hindsight came back with the
jibe that boris johnson was
major sleaze uh well let's get the
thoughts now
uh from our political editor what do you
think well
we were just talking about it that he's
been known in the past as the teflon
tory the man that has a number of
scandals in his personal and his
professional
life but boris johnson seems to breeze
on through it he wins elections and
a senior former cabinet minister said to
me other day the thing with boris
johnson is
it's transactional with the conservative
party they put up with some of the
the heat around him in order to win
elections but there
today he didn't look like it wasn't
sticking
uh he looked really rattled he got
red-faced
he was angry and for uh for
kierstama that um name
calling that he threw back on the prime
minister captain hindsight so pm likes
to call
kierstama the prime minister being major
sleaze
he hopes that that will stick and that
will begin to take the shine off him
with voters and and kierstama saying
that in his terms
the prime minister has now put his head
on the block with that one word denial
no
i didn't talk about body's piling heart
he was clearly
trying to uh set a trap if you like
for the future in the house of commons
uh
getting the prime minister to put on the
record uh that he did not make those
remarks which the prime minister did
and then sir stammer came back and said
uh
that this is um he said i've got it
remind he
he said sorry to the prime minister i
remind him the ministerial code says
ministers who knowingly mislead
parliament will it
be expected to offer their resignation
there'll be more on this believe you me
so kierstarma there
putting it on the record that the prime
minister said no now the calculation of
course
will be that at some point some of the
sources that have accused the prime
minister of saying it and
and leaked that uh will go on the record
but for the time because that's the
confusion isn't it that's the the
some broadcasters and the daily mail
have said look this happened
but we haven't actually got anyone
saying yes i was there and i heard it no
it's all from sources who do not want to
go on the record
and say it the prime minister has on the
record
denied it now it might be that it
there's a
difference in recollection about what
was said or the way it was
phrased but the issue is is whether or
not any sources come on the record and
with that in mind
there's a recording if there could be a
recording and with that in mind you know
dominic commons is going to appear at
a select mature parliamentary hearing
next month in the blog he put out
last week he said that he was happy to
answer all the questions
and publish all his emails and
correspondence that he has had so that
is also hanging over
the prime minister what might he say on
record and could that change
the dynamics and uh
anything else any other important
matters i mean it was nice to see that a
subpostmaster did actually raise the
scandal of the uh
wrongly uh persecuted and prosecuted
subpostmasters and mistresses
well that's obviously been a huge story
about
the postmodern people being wrongly
accused and then losing
their livelihoods and lots of people
outside westminster to say why are you
all focusing on
all of this allegations of sleeves when
there are those sorts of matters but
but actually the the matter of the flat
today
that is a really serious issue it's now
under formal investigation uh the prime
minister there
at pmq's just stonewalling on
what who made the initial payment and
when you're up against the qc
that looks like waffles okay beth well
uh prime minister began by talking about
assistance being sent to india because
the pandemic and lisa nandy now asking
an urgent question on that subject thank
you